Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello and welcome to our podcast the rest is Geschichte well that burst of fluent German may well be leading you to worry that you've downloaded the wrong podcast hello and welcome to beginners German is our new. When Sacha Baron Cohen played a character called Bruno, a kind of Austrian. Yes, of course. Yes.
Yes. Fashion designer, wasn't he? Yes, he was. Yeah, well, thanks, Dominic. Of course, with me is, I'm Tom Holland, with me is Dominic Sandbrook. And why the birth of Deutsche? We may be wondering.
Well, because today our subject is Prussia, Germany, why the birth of the Deutsche? We may be wondering. Well, because today our subject is Prussia, Germany and the birth of the nation, which would become the most powerful European state of the 20th century. And Dominic, before we get into this, I think we should try and establish the parameters because obviously the beginnings of Prussia, you know, we've got to go back to Teutonic Knights. We've got, you know, the pagan Prussians on the shores of the Baltic. So that's where I think we should begin. Well, Tom, my policy is we should, of course, you should, of course, talk about those things. But I think you should talk about them probably on your own after the podcast is finished.
And in order to bolster my case that basically we should talk about what I think is the most interesting period in German history, which is when Germany's just created. So between, let's say, 1870 and the Second World War, we have got an excellent guest who has written a book on just this period called Blood and Iron, Katja Heuer. We have Katja Heuer. How exciting that is. So Katja was born in Germany. She studied at the Friedrich Schiller University. And her book, Blood and Iron, is basically all about, I guess, the Kaiser's Germany. So welcome, Katja. You're now based in Britain. Is that right? I am. Yes. So I'm in Sussex. I've lived here for about 10 years now and I've got dual citizenship as well. So I feel very much part of both countries really now and feel very much at home here too. Well, Katja, Dominic is going to love you because we actually did a we did a podcast earlier on the the causes of the first
world war and dominic was rooting massively um for an anglo-german alliance against the french i'm currently reaching for that so i'm sure that's something we'll come on to and catch it are you do you agree with dominic that um we shouldn't be looking at the the pagan prussians or even frederick the great or napoleon we should be going straight into i guess really the franco-prussian war is where we begin is it um always lead back to the 19th century as far as i'm concerned okay okay okay well could i could i begin just by we've got a question here from ben um de salt de salt um who asked what the hell is Prussia so I think that's
world war and dominic was rooting massively um for an anglo-german alliance against the french i'm currently reaching for that so i'm sure that's something we'll come on to and catch it are you do you agree with dominic that um we shouldn't be looking at the the pagan prussians or even frederick the great or napoleon we should be going straight into i guess really the franco-prussian war is where we begin is it um always lead back to the 19th century as far as i'm concerned okay okay okay well could i could i begin just by we've got a question here from ben um de salt de salt um who asked what the hell is Prussia so i think that's
as good a place to start as any I've never been able to find a concise easy to understand explanation that my America-centric mind can comprehend so I guess Ben is Ben is American but we in England as well are often very ignorant about um Prussian history so um can you just what the hell is Prussia? You started for 10. I think in many ways, even though, you know, that isn't clear because of its geography, really. When you look at how distributed the territory was
throughout its history, that's part of its problem. What the hell is Prussia was probably asked by, you know, people that were trying to reign over it themselves. When you look at either this dualism between Brandenburg and Prussia, which then kind of merged via various alliances and marriages and dynasticism and other issues, even those two territories, the fact that they are miles apart from each other with huge gaps in the middle and later only merge into kind of one big block there
in the north of Germany is in itself a problem. And then, of course, you've got so many different ethnicities there in the Baltic region, you know, trying to later on live all under one political entity, really. I think that in itself explains why there's such problems in understanding, I think, Prussia. And then, of course, the fact that it vanished in the 20th century and is now an entity that doesn't exist anymore makes it more difficult as well so in a nutshell it's an area in the Baltic region in what is now the north of Poland where it sort of originated and the area in Brandenburg that it merged with is in what is now northern Germany so geographically that's where we're sort of located.
The name comes from the sort of original Prussian people that... Let's hear about that. You want to go there? Or the sort of Pulsin people as they're called in German
who were then sort of in quite a horrific and bloody conquest, conquered by the Teutonic Knights as they came back from Crusade, and the Polish king asked them for help to deal with these people in his northern realm that he was
struggling with, and that's where the name stuck, although of course the Germanic people that then settled there weren't the same as the original Prussians, if you will, but their geographical name stuck. Yeah, and then via various different, as I was saying earlier, marriage alliances, inheritances,
conquests and so on, that territory slowly merged closer and closer together there in the north. And the first sort of Prussian well, I suppose once it becomes a kingdom in 1701 you can really see it sort of all merge together. But even then you could argue, you know, if Frederick the Great was still concerned have a kind of densely populated german populated um area there to reign over so that
question is very justified in many ways because it isn't one homogenous nice block where people speak the same language look and talk the same are the same but it's quite a messy um block of different kind of entities before it all gets merged together. And Katya, that raises a slightly different question. I mean, obviously, if we were doing this podcast in 1850, our listeners would have known, kind of had a sense of what Prussia was and Prussian history and all the rest of it. But obviously, Prussia then was subsumed within what was the key actor in creating something called Germany, which we are now very familiar with. One of the things that your book, so your book starts with basically the creation of Germany in 1870, 71. And one of the questions that kind of nags at me, and is there kind of underlying your whole book is it to the
extent to which Germany was basically an artificial creation. So that there was, you know, there was an England, there was clearly a France, but how much do you think Germany was real? And how much was it imagined and invented by Bismarck and the first Kaiser? Well, I think the question is sort of split into fragments. If you ask a liberal or democratic-minded person in the 19th century whether Germany is real, them, it was. I would say certainly since the liberation wars against Napoleon, you know, this idea that the German lands were kind of one entity, and then you've got it contrasted against, say, the French
people or the English people. That idea was there, certainly amongst the sort of liberal elements in the German speaking lands. And there's always this phrase, you know, as far as the German tongue is heard, you know, there should be a Germany. So there was a sense, I think, via linguistic similarities that people felt, you know, they were the same people and ought to be in the same state. And then contrasted to that, you've got all of the people who have an interest in keeping, you know, the separate German states.
So people like Bismarck himself, actually, who were very much kind of minded that they were Prussians, Bavarians, Rhinelanders, Hamburgers, whatever. You always laugh at the hamburger thing, but never mind. So there's all of these different people who had a vested interest in keeping their own political power and their kingdoms and their duchies intact. And certainly didn't didn't feel a sense of kind of German-ness, as it were. So throughout the 19th century, I would say it becomes more real as there are more conflicts of the German speaking lands where they're kind of in one pot against somebody else. And I think that's what defines, in the end, Germany is that it contrasts itself against other peoples because
catchy presumably the reason why um there isn't a kind of a sense of a german state in the way that you have england or france is because all these various german states principalities bishop whatever for centuries and centuries are part of the Holy Roman Empire. And that then gets abolished by Napoleon. And even though Napoleon is defeated, it doesn't get reanimated. And so is there a sense between the ending of the Holy Roman Empire and the emergence of what becomes the German Empire, that in a sense, people are looking around for a way to kind of re-establish a sense of unity? Or are most of the states happy now to kind of re-establish a sense of unity or are most of the states happy to now to kind of basically be independent i think it's a slightly because the the german
empire that emerges of the second reich if you will and it's called the second reich because it's trying to create some sort of um i suppose a sense of continuity between the holy roman empire and that but it's much more unified in you know that it actually becomes a nation state um with the centralized government so when you look at the holy roman emperor and the way that he had to like almost haggle every time he wants to go to war you know will people actually join him will they actually be with him because there wasn't a sense that people say in prussia were necessarily directly um in the same like you know construct or unit as people say Bavaria were, and their interests quite often diverge completely.
empire that emerges of the second reich if you will and it's called the second reich because it's trying to create some sort of um i suppose a sense of continuity between the holy roman empire and that but it's much more unified in you know that it actually becomes a nation state   with the centralized government so when you look at the holy roman emperor and the way that he had to like almost haggle every time he wants to go to war you know will people actually join him will they actually be with him because there wasn't a sense that people say in prussia were necessarily directly   in the same like you know construct or unit as people say Bavaria were, and their interests quite often diverge completely.
Whilst I think from 1871 there is more of a sense of they are now in one state and need to pull together, and I think that's of course, as I was trying to say in my book as well, that's of course perpetuated with this kind of constant conflict that people are trying to create almost artificially to try and keep the Germans together. But I don't think the Holy Roman Empire had that to the same extent. I think that was more of a loose kind of conglomerate whilst 1871 actually creates a nation sense in the actual sense of the word.
In your book, though, that moment is – so you basically describe how the Second Reich is created through war, don't you? You have three wars. They fight the Danes, the Austrians, who are German-speaking, but are basically shut out of the new German creation, and then the French. And you sort of, I mean, the title Blood and Iron is from Bismarck, but it's obviously, you know, imbued with this sort of sense that it's all a very militaristic project
and the army is crucial and a sense of fighting other people and all the rest of it. Do you think that makes – I don't know how – I don't think you do kind of sign up to the Sonderweg idea, which is that basically Germany had this weird special path that explains what happened to it in the 20th century. But do you think Germany's beginnings were more bloody, more militaristic, and that the
essence of the nation was you know to do with fighting in a way that it wasn't of other european nations i certainly don't subscribe to the whole sondervik theory in the sense that you know i find it slightly too deterministic for my own liking like this idea that it was failed from the start i think that's something i tried tried to sort of contrast in the book or kind of question in the book. But I do think the problem, the inherent problem in this 1871 creation is indeed that it's based at that moment, it's based on blood and iron. I think as Bismarck was saying it was, I think he was completely,
you know, he's a very observant man and I think realised that that was the problem with it. And he himself actually, even still as late as 1868, he still said he doesn't think the creation of a German state is possible within this century. He was still saying three years before he did it, you know, it's going to take another three decades to do it. And that tells you everything you need to know. I think in that moment, it's a forced way of doing it because you wouldn't have been able to get, say, the southern states in particular, Bavaria and Baden on board because they were politically there and say we didn't want to be Prussian either. But I think, you know, in this kind of northern bloc, I think it was easier to achieve for cultural reasons than, say,
getting the very liberal people in Baden on side or the very arch Catholic people in Bavaria. So it took conquest at that point, I think. Katja, just to turn that on its head. Could you not also argue that in a way, Germany kind of wills itself into being, not because it's a land of soldiers, but because it's a land of philosophers and the kind of the dream of nationalism, the kind of the idealism that you'd associate with Kant, you know, probably after Frederick the Great, the most famous Prussian before Bismarck, and the Brothers Grimm, the idea that, you know, the kind of identity that
is deep in the forest and the soil and everything. I mean, that's also a very important part of how Germany kind of imagines itself into being, isn't it? Or have I got that wrong? No, I completely agree. I think that that's exactly that dualism, you know, that I was trying to describe earlier between the sort of liberal elements and the elites. I think it's exactly the same if you contrast the soldiers and the philosophers with each other. So there are, of course, people like Hegel,
Arndt, Kant, as you mentioned, kind of where there's a long German tradition, really, of thinking in a particular way or political thought and philosophical thought in that sense. And people like Hegel, for instance, were actively pushing to have germany unified as well and were part of the um unifying forces but i think without then the middle class is joining in without because they wanted unification for economic reasons really um and were then buying into all of those philosophical
Arndt, Kant, as you mentioned, kind of where there's a long German tradition, really, of thinking in a particular way or political thought and philosophical thought in that sense. And people like Hegel, for instance, were actively pushing to have germany unified as well and were part of the um unifying forces but i think without then the middle class is joining in without because they wanted unification for economic reasons really   and were then buying into all of those philosophical
ideas um you know alongside their economic interests, really, you get a kind of growing sense of something needs to happen, something needs to, or somebody needs to basically join Germany. But I think the fact that it happened, or the reason why it happened then when it happened in 1871 was down to Blood and Iron and Bismarck and the conquest. I think eventually it would have happened in any case and probably in a different way.
ideas   u know alongside their economic interests, really, you get a kind of growing sense of something needs to happen, something needs to, or somebody needs to basically join Germany. But I think the fact that it happened, or the reason why it happened then when it happened in 1871 was down to Blood and Iron and Bismarck and the conquest. I think eventually it would have happened in any case and probably in a different way.
But as Bismarck says, probably 30, 40 years on rather than at that particular point in time. A regular listener to this podcast will not be surprised. Tom asks about philosophers. I want to ask a question about, I don't know, plumbers. So at what point do... You asked about soldiers, Dominic. I did, I did. Soldiers first, plumbers second. That's the way my mind works. So at what point does the sort of common man and woman, at what point do they start thinking of themselves as Germans? And the one reason I ask is because I've recently been reading a lot of stuff about the First World War. And it's really striking there how, you know, when there's sort of Christmas truces or whatever, and people are fraternizing with the British, people from Baden or something will say, oh, we're really nice and we're just like you, but the Prussians are complete monsters.
And it's clear there are big divisions, and they think of themselves sometimes state first, country, maybe not country second, but their state identity is really important to them. At what point did those things cross over? So at what point did Germans think of themselves as Germans first and Württembergers or Bavarians or Prussians second, if at all? Yeah, I would say it started once again with the Napoleonic Wars. So when you look at, you know, when Frederick Wilhelm III comes out and actually calls first on all Prussians and then on all Germans to join him, and this actually works. And then you've got really kind of unifying moments,
like, you know, what is now called the Battle of the Nations, like the Battle of Leipzig, where there's a sense that this is like a national effort almost, even though, of course, the Austrians and other sort of nations, if you will, joined in with that as well. But there is a sense that if Germans fight together, they can do this. They can even drive somebody, you know, like the mighty Napoleon out.
So in a way, the paradox is that Napoleon, in a sense, is the godfather of a united Germany. Absolutely. And that is one of the great, you know, sort of really momentary tricks played by history. Yeah, indeed. Well well it started already when you think that you know there were over 400 little states in the holy roman empire and napoleon unified them into the 39 states that were then still left after the congress of vienna in 1815 so in many ways he is he is a great lever of unification if you will um and the other thing is because that this was largely a or kind of certainly to large elements, a volunteer force. So you got the famous Lützer volunteers who then gave Germany the colours, the black, red and gold colours on their uniforms, that kind of stuff.
So in a way, the paradox is that Napoleon, in a sense, is the godfather of a united Germany. Absolutely. And that is one of the great, you know, sort of really momentary tricks played by history. Yeah, indeed. Well well it started already when you think that you know there were over 400 little states in the holy roman empire and napoleon unified them into the 39 states that were then still left after the congress of vienna in 1815 so in many ways he is he is a great lever of unification if you will   and the other thing is because that this was largely a or kind of certainly to large elements, a volunteer force. So you got the famous Lützer volunteers who then gave Germany the colours, the black, red and gold colours on their uniforms, that kind of stuff.
So the fact that this is like the people fighting, you know, rather than the state telling them they have to, they volunteer. There's lots of, even at that point, women, children, civilians that join in by, you know, huge volunteer campaigns and donating metal and all that kind of stuff. So I think Germans began to feel at the beginning of the 19th century that, you know, if they rally together, if they pull together against somebody distinctly foreign by their language, by their culture and so on, that there is a sense of unity and you see that again in the 1840 french scare when when the french king louis philippe thought you know he's gonna say he was gonna sort his own internal problems out by doing a bit of saber rattling and he was you know disputing various territories along the river rhine and so on and all of a sudden you get demonstrations all over germany and that answers perhaps your question uh dominic, about ordinary people, that this wasn't instigated by the state. There's ordinary people in 1840 going out in Baden, in Bayern, in, you know, everywhere, basically all over Germany, going out on the street saying, this is our River Rhine. And,
So the fact that this is like the people fighting, you know, rather than the state telling them they have to, they volunteer. There's lots of, even at that point, women, children, civilians that join in by, you know, huge volunteer campaigns and donating metal and all that kind of stuff. So I think Germans began to feel at the beginning of the 19th century that, you know, if they rally together, if they pull together against somebody distinctly foreign by their language, by their culture and so on, that there is a sense of unity and you see that again in the 1840 french scare when when the french king louis philippe thought you know he's gonna say he was gonna sort his own internal problems out by doing a bit of saber rattling and he was you know disputing various territories along the river rhine and so on and all of a sudden you get demonstrations all over germany and that answers perhaps your question
uh dominic, about ordinary people, that this wasn't instigated by the state. There's ordinary people in 1840 going out in Baden, in Bayern, in, you know, everywhere, basically all over Germany, going out on the street saying, this is our River Rhine. And,
you know, this kind of myth of the watch on the Rhine and all that, you know, is beginning to emerge then as a kind of German concept. There are now Bavarians somehow worried about what's going on, you know, at the River Rhine, which gives you some sort of idea that they feel a sense of connection to the people that live there, even though they're not traditionally speaking, historically speaking in the same territory. So I think it's those moments of conflict again, you know, going back to the same idea that brings ordinary people out um and kind of gets them on on side with the middle classes and the and the liberals and those
you know, this kind of myth of the watch on the Rhine and all that, you know, is beginning to emerge then as a kind of German concept. There are now Bavarians somehow worried about what's going on, you know, at the River Rhine, which gives you some sort of idea that they feel a sense of connection to the people that live there, even though they're not traditionally speaking, historically speaking in the same territory. So I think it's those moments of conflict again, you know, going back to the same idea that brings ordinary people out   and kind of gets them on on side with the middle classes and the and the liberals and those
kind of social classes that have from an intellectual point argued for can i ask a question sorry tom i know i'm jumping in again uh can i ask a question though about a bit of germany or a bit of german-speaking europe that doesn't fit in um which is austria so obviously they fight against the austrians in order to set up Germany. But Austria has this weird place because, I mean, if you'll forgive me for saying, the single best known German of all time was Austrian. And the single greatest, you know,
kind of social classes that have from an intellectual point argued for can i ask a question sorry tom i know i'm jumping in again   uh can i ask a question though about a bit of germany or a bit of german-speaking europe that doesn't fit in   which is austria so obviously they fight against the austrians in order to set up Germany. But Austria has this weird place because, I mean, if you'll forgive me for saying, the single best known German of all time was Austrian. And the single greatest, you know,
the man who talked more loudly anyway and more stridently about German unity and German-ness was an Austrian. And that's always kind of puzzled me that sort of hitler must have had an accent and he must have seemed to some germans surely like an outsider didn't or not i mean where does what do how does austria fit into the kind of german imagination well just briefly on the hitler thing um again it seems all discussion leads all discussions lead back to him
the man who talked more loudly anyway and more stridently about German unity and German-ness was an Austrian. And that's always kind of puzzled me that sort of hitler must have had an accent and he must have seemed to some germans surely like an outsider didn't or not i mean where does what do how does austria fit into the kind of german imagination well just briefly on the hitler thing   again it seems all discussion leads all discussions lead back to him
um but he was acutely aware of that and actually trained himself to have a kind of quite over the top bavarian accent so that that kind of really harsh accent that you hear in you know those speeches and things that that you see um you know mostly now on on tv and documentaries and stuff that's a bavarian accent and he's deliberately gone out of his way to try and acquire that, you know, and make sure that he sounds German, German rather than Austrian German. So that's one thing maybe on that one. He was quite, you know, himself quite consciously aware of that fact.
um but he was acutely aware of that and actually trained himself to have a kind of quite over the top bavarian accent so that that kind of really harsh accent that you hear in you know those speeches and things that that you see   you know mostly now on on tv and documentaries and stuff that's a bavarian accent and he's deliberately gone out of his way to try and acquire that, you know, and make sure that he sounds German, German rather than Austrian German. So that's one thing maybe on that one. He was quite, you know, himself quite consciously aware of that fact.
And then Austria is a weird one because they've always got, you know, with the Austro-Hungarian Empire, they've always got one foot in the East in that sense. that sense and if you know from a german unification point of view um and with this whole like you know as far as the german tongue is heard you could have maybe had the german-speaking part of austria eventually joined that in the way that hitler did as well with with the angeles but the fact that they would have never given up the other side, you know, the sort of Eastern European side with a multitude of different peoples and languages and cultures in that, I think would have made this kind of intellectual German-ness thing that underpinned German unification to some extent, I think difficult to, you know, to sell. And certainly
And then Austria is a weird one because they've always got, you know, with the Austro-Hungarian Empire, they've always got one foot in the East in that sense. that sense and if you know from a german unification point of view   and with this whole like you know as far as the german tongue is heard you could have maybe had the german-speaking part of austria eventually joined that in the way that hitler did as well with with the angeles but the fact that they would have never given up the other side, you know, the sort of Eastern European side with a multitude of different peoples and languages and cultures in that, I think would have made this kind of intellectual German-ness thing that underpinned German unification to some extent, I think difficult to, you know, to sell. And certainly
in terms of real political terms, I think it would have been difficult unless you create a mahoos of German empire in the centre of Europe, which, again, you know, would have encompassed a lot of millions of non-German, ethnically and linguistically non-German people. So I think that's part of what made it so difficult. And then, of course, the dualism between Austria and Prussia wouldn't have been solved within a German unit. Well, so much still to talk about. I think we should take a break here. But when we come back, we've got lots of questions and lots more Prussian history to explore. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is history we're talking prussia emergence of germany uh all such things like that um catch up we would we were talking about austria and um germany i could i just ask you a question about prussia as a state that is kind of more recent than many of the uh you know the cities that line the rhine that often go back to the kind of more recent than many of the, you know, the cities that line the Rhine,
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is history we're talking prussia emergence of germany uh all such things like that   um catch up we would we were talking about austria and   um germany i could i just ask you a question about prussia as a state that is kind of more recent than many of the   uh you know the cities that line the rhine that often go back to the kind of more recent than many of the, you know, the cities that line the Rhine,
often go back to the kind of Roman times. And those cities must have a sense of their antiquity, perhaps of their cultural superiority, and a sense of Prussia as a kind of parvenu. Is that an issue for Germans in the 19th century, the sense that, do they feel perhaps rather as the French and the British do, that the Prussians are kind of upstarts? I think so, to some extent. I mean, Bismarck himself uses this metaphor. I think I talk about that in the book as well, if I haven't cut it out. No, and compares it to the old Austrian ship that's much kind of slower, grander, bigger, but also about to sink. And so in many ways, there's this idea that Prussia is a trim, modern, industrialized
entity, whilst the other powers are old and crumbling. And I think they deliberately make use of that kind of lack of ancient history in that sense, because it fits in, doesn't it, with industrialisation, with the military and with all of those things. And I'm right. I mean, basically, Britain is the first industrial nation. But over the 19th century, the British seem to spend all their time worrying that actually, Germany is massively overtaking them, presumably because Germany is. Germany is by far the most industrially sophisticated country in Europe. It's the speed of the catch up as well that worries everyone. So when you look at just how quickly they overtake Britain in things like steel production,
obviously, which Britain hasn't naturally got all that much of, all of these kind of in coal and things like that. So all of the elements really that you need for, you know, industry and for military as well, or for the economy and so on. It's that that worries people. So by 1914, pretty much, you know, you've got the second largest Navy, for instance, in the world out of nothing within just a few decades. So people were looking at that, wondering, you know,
give it another 10, 20 years and see where that's going. So yes, I think that's very much a concern. It's basically, it goes back once again to the Napoleonic Wars when the Rhineland was given to Prussia in 1815. And I don't know why, but nobody seems to have thought much of it. The Austrians certainly completely underestimated that. They thought, oh, good, we got rid of that problem of having to look after the pesky Belgians, which, you know, had been annoying the Habsburg for ages.
And they always needed to send troops up there to keep them at bay. And they were kind of thinking, oh, let Prussia do that. That's fine. And give them the Rhineland. And all of a sudden, you know, they get all the coal, iron ore and everything else and end up being an industrial superpower. We have a question on that very theme from Nicholas Walton, who asked, was Prussia's influence over Western Germany and the subsequent 20th century misadventures all britain's fault
for its post-napoleonic settlement dominic shaking his head at that yeah that's always britain's fault isn't it yeah i'd agree with that so it most definitely is and i mean britain was i mean you know you got to put that into context of napoleon just having you know literally gone over the entire continent and conquered it in no time and there was certainly a sense that the balance of power in europe needed to be restored and then you look at austria and austria hasn't actually changed you know like basically people sat there wondering well you couldn't keep napoleon at bay in the state that you were in then what's changed now you know what's going to happen if the french do it again and so there was a sense that prussia had now emerged as a valid trustworthy reliable
for its post-napoleonic settlement dominic shaking his head at that   yeah that's always britain's fault isn't it yeah i'd agree with that so it most definitely is and i mean britain was i mean you know you got to put that into context of napoleon just having you know literally gone over the entire continent and conquered it in no time and there was certainly a sense that the balance of power in europe needed to be restored and then you look at austria and austria hasn't actually changed   you know like basically people sat there wondering well you couldn't keep napoleon at bay in the state that you were in then what's changed now   you know what's going to happen if the french do it again and so there was a sense that prussia had now emerged as a valid trustworthy reliable
ally on the continent bear in mind that they fought on the same side as well you know there was no reason whatsoever to suspect the prussians of the later catastrophes that would eventually ensue, you know, like literally a century later. So to sit there and go, oh, this is all Britain's fault seems a bit odd. So the idea that there was another strong stabilising force on the continent to counterbalance French power was appealing to all sides, really, in Europe. There are lots of questions about this and about Prussia. And basically, hanging over a lot of these questions is World War I. So for example, somebody called Pharaoh Man says, Prussian militarism is a well-worn cliche. So obviously, it was a huge British newspaper cliche in the 1910s. As a society, he says, was Prussia really
ally on the continent bear in mind that they fought on the same side as well   you know there was no reason whatsoever to suspect the prussians of the later catastrophes that would eventually ensue, you know, like literally a century later. So to sit there and go, oh, this is all Britain's fault seems a bit odd. So the idea that there was another strong stabilising force on the continent to counterbalance French power was appealing to all sides, really, in Europe. There are lots of questions about this and about Prussia. And basically, hanging over a lot of these questions is World War I. So for example, somebody called Pharaoh Man says, Prussian militarism is a well-worn cliche. So obviously, it was a huge British newspaper cliche in the 1910s. As a society, he says, was Prussia really
that militaristic? And was it militaristic in ways that were completely different from other countries? And just to sort of follow up on his question, I think France proportionately had more men under arms in 1914 than Germany did. You know, France was a more obviously militaristic country, I would argue, than Germany was, even though we don't really remember it that way. But anyway, Katya, you'll have your own answer. I think you may disagree with me, actually. You think it was very militaristic, don't really remember it that way but anyway katya you'll have your own answer i think you may disagree with me actually you think it was very militaristic don't you fairly i think the problem is that it's uh culturally a slightly different thing and again that stems from those landwehr and volunteer units in the and the napoleonic wars so the moment you have a significant proportion
that militaristic? And was it militaristic in ways that were completely different from other countries? And just to sort of follow up on his question, I think France proportionately had more men under arms in 1914 than Germany did. You know, France was a more obviously militaristic country, I would argue, than Germany was, even though we don't really remember it that way. But anyway, Katya, you'll have your own answer. I think you may disagree with me, actually. You think it was very militaristic, don't really remember it that way but anyway katya you'll have your own answer i think you may disagree with me actually you think it was very militaristic don't you fairly i think the problem is that it's   uh culturally a slightly different thing and again that stems from those landwehr and volunteer units in the and the napoleonic wars so the moment you have a significant proportion
of your country you know as a like effectively like a militia force, it seeps into society in a much more deep-seated way, I think. And that, I think, is part of Prussia's problem, is that where it's located in the centre of Europe and where it's completely vulnerable throughout its history to the surrounding powers, there has always been a huge sense of the people need to defend this or else you know they had the experience of things like um the well obviously the you know the the napoleonic wars but also before that um you get the 30 years war for example completely ravaging the country and so i think the sense of people need to be soldiers is much much more deep-seated psychologically i think in prussia than it is in other countries necessarily.
你的国家你知道的，实际上就像民兵部队一样，它以一种更深蒂固的方式渗透进社会，我是这么认为的。而我认为，这也是普鲁士问题的一部分，就是它位于欧洲中心的位置，并且在其整个历史上都完全容易受到周围大国的攻击，人们一直有一种强烈的观念，即人们需要保卫这个国家，否则，你知道的，他们有过这样的经历，嗯，很明显，你知道的，拿破仑战争，但也在此之前，嗯，比如三十年战争彻底蹂躏了这个国家，所以我认为，在普鲁士，人们需要成为士兵的这种观念，在心理上比在其他国家要深刻得多。
Where in France, of course, you've got a longstanding and fine military tradition, but it's not necessarily part of society in the same way, I think, that it is in Prussia. Having said that, Prussia is also, on the other hand, an extremely liberal and tolerant state, and that's often forgotten. And this is something I wanted to raise, you know, with the book as well is that you get religious tolerance to a degree that you hardly see anywhere else in Europe, you know, with the,
而在法国，当然，你们有长期而优秀的军事传统，但它不一定以同样的方式成为社会的一部分，我认为，普鲁士就是这样。话虽如此，从另一方面来说，普鲁士也是一个极其自由和宽容的国家，而这一点往往被遗忘。这也是我想提出来的一点，你知道的，关于这本书也是，你得到了你在欧洲其他地方几乎看不到的宗教宽容，你知道的，通过，
obviously starting with the, or you could argue basically is constantly in that state because it has got Protestant and Catholic elements within its realm and needs to deal with that. So, you know, you get Frederick the Great, obviously, even his father as well. There's huge religious tolerance there that leads to a flourishing of culture. You get this whole, you know, refugee movement from France with French Protestants, with the Huguenots fleeing and, you know, masses of them coming to Britain. And again, largely intellectuals and tradespeople and people like that bringing their own culture with them.
很明显从，或者你可以说基本上一直处于那种状态，因为它在其领土内有新教和天主教元素，需要处理这个问题。所以，你知道的，你有腓特烈大帝，很明显，甚至还有他的父亲。那里有巨大的宗教宽容，这导致了文化的繁荣。你会看到整个，你知道的，来自法国的难民潮，法国新教徒，胡格诺派逃亡，你知道的，他们中的大量人员来到英国。同样，主要是知识分子、商人和诸如此类的人，他们把自己的文化带到了这里。
So I think the fact that Prussia is also a very cultural, very intellectual, very philosophical state is often overlooked, but I don't think that necessarily takes away from the role that the military plays. The Prussian king or all of the Prussian kings really themselves in the 19th century are hugely concerned about that about this um element of like landfail units and and um militia element basically within their armed forces at each point it makes up something between 10 and 20 percent i think of the prussian forces are always volunteer forces and they're mega liberal mega conscious of their germanness and they're loyal to what they see as the fatherland, i.e. some construct of Germany and not Prussia. And that's kind of something
所以我觉得，普鲁士也是一个非常具文化、非常具知识性、非常具哲学性的国家这一事实常常被忽视，但我认为这并不一定剥夺了军队所扮演的角色。普鲁士国王或19世纪的所有普鲁士国王，其实他们自己在当时都非常关注这一点，关于这种类似地方后备军单位和嗯民兵元素的成分，基本上存在于他们各个时期的武装力量中，它大约占了普鲁士军队的10%到20%之间，我认为普鲁士军队总是由志愿军组成，他们超级自由，超级有他们的德国意识，他们忠于他们所认为的祖国，也就是某种德国的概念，而不是普鲁士。而这正是某种
that they worry about. Brismac actually says that blood and iron speech in the context of military reforms that the Prussian king is trying to push through parliament where he wants to eradicate those volunteer units and completely restructure the Prussian military into a kind of professional force that is largely consistent
他们担心的事情。俾斯麦实际上是在普鲁士国王试图在议会通过的军事改革的背景下发表那篇血铁演讲的，他想根除那些志愿部队，将普鲁士军队彻底重组为一种职业化的军队，这种军队很大程度上由
of just professional soldiers rather than volunteers because he's so concerned about their mindset and their loyalties that he doesn't see them as a professional armed force basically, but as something that might potentially be a problem if you get another 1848-type revolution. So I think it's a bit of both and and it seems a contrast but or a kind of conflict between the two but it's not necessarily one okay well kind of on that theme we've got a question from robert gowers who asks how much merit is there to the
仅仅是职业军人而不是志愿者组成，因为他太担心他们的心态和忠诚了，以至于他基本上不认为他们是一支职业武装力量，而是一支如果再发生一次1848年式革命可能会成为问题的力量。所以我觉得这是两者的结合，而且这看起来是一个对比，或者是两者之间的一种冲突，但这不一定是一个，好吧，顺着这个主题，我们有一个来自罗伯特·高尔斯的问题，他问，
idea held by conrad at an hour that germany could only become a truly democratic country if its prussian influences or prussianism were removed. And just to kind of slightly put a spin on that question, it's almost impossible, isn't it, to look at the history of 19th century Germany and Prussia specifically without an awareness of what happens with Nazi Germany. And do you think without that catastrophe, our sense of Prussia would be different? That we would kind of emphasise perhaps a bit more the way that, you know, the incredible liberal strains within it, its incredible intellectual and cultural achievements, rather than the image of, you know, spiked helmets and
康拉德·阿登纳持有的那种观点有多少道理，即德国只有在清除了其普鲁士影响或普鲁士主义之后，才能成为一个真正的民主国家？稍微转折一下这个问题，几乎不可能，不是吗，在不了解纳粹德国所发生的事情的情况下，去看19世纪德国特别是普鲁士的历史。你是否认为如果没有这场灾难，我们对普鲁士的看法会不同？我们可能会更多地强调，你知道的，其中令人难以置信的自由主义倾向，其不可思议的知识和文化成就，而不是那种，你知道的，尖顶头盔和
goose stepping and so on, which is what certainly in this country, and you must be more than very aware of this, is what tends to get emphasised. Yeah, indeed. I think we're partially falling into the trap of listening to Nazi propaganda with that as well, I think. I mean, the way that Hitler directly tried to put himself,
鹅步等等的形象，这在英国肯定是这样的，而且你一定非常清楚这一点，这往往是得到强调的。是的，确实如此。我认为我们在某种程度上也落入了听信纳粹宣传的陷阱。我的意思是，希特勒直接试图将自己定位的方式，
just with the very word, the Third Reich, going there and sort of saying, oh, this is now the successor state to the Second Reich, which in turn is the successor state to the first. And quite famously, you know, he had that portrait of Frederick the Great down in the bunker with him in the last days in Berlin in 1945 and all of that. So I think to some extent it's the Nazis' own propaganda that sought to draw a line there, basically a straight line from Prussia to the Nazis. You have the Day of Potsdam of course, which Hitler again uses as a means of drawing continuity between Prussia and
仅仅通过“第三帝国”这个词，去到那里并有点像在说，哦，这现在是第二帝国的继承国，而第二帝国反过来又是第一帝国的继承国。而且非常著名的是，你知道的，在1945年柏林最后的日子里，他在地堡里挂着腓特烈大帝的肖像，诸如此类。所以我认为在某种程度上，正是纳粹自己的宣传试图在那里划一条线，基本上是从普鲁士到纳粹画一条直线。当然，你还有波茨坦日，希特勒再次将其用作在普鲁士和
his term. So what is that? I don't know about that. So the Day of Potsdam was Hitler's way of getting Hindenburg's approval for his reign in public um and so they basically meet up um in public and hindenburg's shaking hitler's hands um and you have this this kind of prussian insignia everywhere so rather than having the nazi flags kind of you know plastered all over the place they're using a lot of sort of iron crosses and and sort of prussian insignia really to try and draw a similarity there. And this is somewhat ironic given that Franz von Papen had actually abolished,
他的政权之间建立连续性的手段。那么，那是什么？我不知道这个。所以波茨坦日是希特勒在公众面前获得兴登堡对他统治的批准的方式，嗯，所以他们基本上在公众场合见面，嗯，兴登堡与希特勒握手，嗯，你到处都能看到这种这种普鲁士徽章，所以他们没有把纳粹旗帜到处贴满，而是使用了大量的铁十字勋章和某种普鲁士徽章，真的试图在那里画出相似之处。这具有一定的讽刺意味，鉴于弗朗茨·冯·帕彭实际上已经废除了，
practically abolished Prussia in the so-called Prussian coup in 1932, where he literally integrated it using Article 48, literally integrated it into the German kind of federal system in a way that practically abolished it. So in many ways, people always talk about the abolishment of Prussia in 1947. In many ways, it got abolished in 1932. And yet Hitler is keen to, he doesn't restore that. So Hitler sticks with the centralized state, you know, and doesn't allow Prussia any power back itself. But nonetheless, likes the idea of, you know, there was always militarism there. So we are a militaristic society. So let's stick with that. And I think that's stuck because of Hitler's brilliant propaganda in the sense of it, you know, its effect on people.
在1932年所谓的普鲁士政变中实际上废除了普鲁士，当时他字面意义上通过第48条将其整合，字面意义上将其整合到德国的某种联邦制系统中，从实际意义上废除了它。所以在很多方面，人们总是在谈论1947年普鲁士的废除。在很多方面，它在1932年就被废除了。然而希特勒渴望，他并没有恢复那个。所以希特勒坚持集权国家，你知道的，不允许普鲁士恢复任何权力。但尽管如此，还是喜欢这样的想法，你知道的，那里一直存在军国主义。所以我们是一个军国主义社会。所以让我们坚持这一点。我认为这之所以能坚持下来，是因为希特勒出色的宣传，从其对人们的影响这个意义上来说，
I think that's echoed through the ages and we still have that now, I think. But the military opposition to Hitler, I mean, that was kind of prussian as well wasn't it yeah i think both both the loyalty and the um you know this kind of misplaced misplaced sense of loyalty that prussian officers officers felt due to their you know sense of obedience and duty and all of that basically to them their kind of ethos as a military is they're like the watchdog basically of the state they don't get involved in politics they do what they're what they're told and they do it well. And that's, I think, partially, you know, responsible for the devastation caused in the Second World War.
我认为这在历代中都有回响，我们现在依然有这种感觉，我认为。但是对希特勒的军事反对，我的意思是，那也是某种普鲁士式的，不是吗？是的，我认为既有忠诚，也有嗯，你知道的，普鲁士军官由于他们的服从感、责任感以及所有这些而感到的这种错位的、错位的忠诚感，基本上对他们来说，他们作为军队的某种精神是，他们就像国家的看门狗，他们不参与政治，他们做他们被告知要做的事，而且他们把它做好。我认为，这在很大程度上要为第二次世界大战造成的毁灭负责。
And then on the flip side, you've also got, of course, huge Prussian opposition as per July plot in 1944. So in many ways, you can see both elements there. I think a Prussian conscience and the Prussian sense of duty and obedience, both leading to, you know, what we see in the Second World War. I want to just follow up Katya on Tom's question. I agree, by the way, that with what Tom said, I mean, it's impossible really to talk about German history without the, even if you try to banish it, you know, that the specter of Nazism is kind of hanging over you to some extent as a historian. But also, I think, the First World War too, because, you know, the sort of the discussion about Germany being flawed from the outset and Germany being militaristic, I mean, that didn't
然后在另一方面，当然，你也有巨大的普鲁士反对派，也就是1944年的七月阴谋。所以在很多方面，你都可以看到这两个要素。我认为普鲁士人的良知以及普鲁士人的责任感和服从意识，都导致了，你知道的，我们在第二次世界大战中看到的情况。卡蒂亚，我想接着汤姆的问题问一下。顺便说一句，我同意汤姆所说的话，我的意思是，在不谈论德国历史的情况下，即使你试图驱逐它，你知道的，纳粹主义的幽灵作为历史学家在某种程度上依然悬在你头顶上。但同时，我认为第一次世界大战也是如此，因为，你知道的，那种关于德国从一开始就有缺陷且具有军国主义的讨论，我的意思是，那并没有
begin in the Second World War. That was all there in British propaganda, particularly in the middle of the First World War, that the Germans were uniquely, you know, rapacious or greedy and sort of enslaved by their generals and all this sort of stuff. And hanging over a lot of the questions from the listeners is basically Prussian and German responsibility for World War I. Now, we had a podcast that generated tons of discussion about the causes of World War I. And I'm wondering, in your book, you seem to go along with the idea that ultimately you think it's Germany's fault or that Germany bears a huge share of the responsibility for the war, that it is the blank check, the Kaiser's ambitions, all this sort of stuff.
从第二次世界大战开始。这全都在英国的宣传中，特别是在第一次世界大战中期，说德国人是出奇地，你知道的，贪婪的，或者说被他们的将军们奴役了，诸如此类的事情。而悬在听众许多问题上方的是普鲁士和德国对第一次世界大战的责任。现在，我们有一个播客引发了大量关于第一次世界大战起因的讨论。我想知道，在你的书中，你似乎赞同这样一种观点，即你最终认为这是德国的错，或者说德国对这场战争负有巨大的责任，这就是空白支票、德皇的野心，所有这些事情。
Do you want to say a bit more about that? Do you think it was Germany's fault, the First World War? Well, I was trying to see it from a German perspective, and I think I wouldn't go as far as to say it is Germany's fault in the sense that they were deliberately causing a world war. But I do think they were taking the view that conflict was helpful for the internal divisions that were still there so bismarck had tried his best obviously for better or worse with his various different policies to unite germans but it was blatantly obvious by the time that willem came into power that socially culturally religiously germans were still hugely divided and that realm was constantly at risk of breaking
你想再多说一点吗？你认为第一次世界大战是德国的错吗？嗯，我是试图从德国的角度来看待这个问题，我想我不会走那么远去说这是德国的错，意思是他们是故意挑起一场世界大战的。但我确实认为他们当时的看法是，冲突对于仍然存在的内部裂痕是有帮助的，所以俾斯麦显然已经尽了最大努力，无论好坏，通过他各种不同的政策来团结德国人，但当威廉掌权时，这是昭然若揭的，从社会、文化、宗教上讲，德国人仍然严重分裂，那个帝国不断面临着破裂的风险
apart and i think when in when it became more obvious that that conflict in some shape or form could be lived again you know bearing in mind that there hadn't been a war since the franco-prussian war and and that was by that time what four decades more than four decades away they needed something um otherwise that that realm was breaking apart there was this you know famous period that's often called, well, you can see it as stagnation really if you want to, but it was certainly almost a crisis from about 1912 to 1914. Whilst it didn't seem that way,
而且我认为，当越来越明显的是，某种形式的冲突可以再次上演时（请记住，自普法战争以来就没有发生过战争，而且到那时已经是，什么，四代人，超过四代人以前的事了），他们需要一些东西，否则那个帝国就要分崩离析了。当时有一个著名的时期，通常被称为，嗯，如果你愿意的话，你可以把它看作是停滞，但它从1912年到1914年几乎肯定是一场危机。虽然看起来不像那样，
there were no great uprisings or anything like that, but there was complete standstill in the Reichstag. The trade unions were swelling in ranks. There was some sort of sense that a crisis internally was about to erupt. And I think Wilhelm and the militaries accepted that they needed something to deal with that, and the war seemed a good idea in that sense. So bearing in mind as well that the First World War is on a scale
没有发生大的起义或诸如此类的事情，但国会处于完全瘫痪状态。工会的人数在激增。有一种内部危机即将爆发的感觉。我认为威廉和军方接受了他们需要做点什么来处理这个问题，在这个意义上，战争似乎是个好主意。所以也要记住，第一次世界大战的规模
that people just hadn't anticipated, they literally just thought they were going to have another, I think, sort of 1870 or maybe a bit bigger in the Balkans and that would be the end of that. Willem in particular was so deluded about the fact that Britain wouldn't get involved, surely not his family and all the rest of it, that I think, you know, if you want to put the blame on them for that, yes,
是人们根本没有预料到的，他们实际上只是以为他们将要经历另一场，我认为，类似于1870年的战争，或者在巴尔干半岛规模稍大一点，那就结束了。尤其是威廉，对英国不会卷入这一点产生了极大的错觉，他的家人肯定不会卷入其中，其余的一切也是如此，所以我想，如果你想把责任归咎于他们，是的，
but I don't think they were willingly walking into a world war with the possible exception actually of Moltke maybe, because he had this thing about being Moltke the Younger and needing to step into the footsteps of his famous uncle, Moltke the Elder, who'd kind of made his name in the Franco-Prussian War. So I think with him, there's a bit more ambition there. And do you think we're too hard generally on the Kaiser, on Wilhelm II? Do you think we, you know, he's basically a slightly pitiful comic figure,
但我认为他们并不是甘愿走向一场世界大战，可能毛奇是个例外，因为他有这种执念，觉得自己是小毛奇，需要追随他著名的叔叔老毛奇的脚步，老毛奇曾在普法战争中扬名立万。所以我觉得在他身上，有更多的野心。你觉得我们对德皇威廉二世是不是总体上太苛刻了？你觉得我们，你知道的，他基本上是一个有点可怜的滑稽人物，
isn't he? Rather than this sort of all-conquering, spiked helmet kind of... I'd go with that, yeah. I mean, that's not to absolve him from his responsibility and from what he effectively did. I mean, the buck stops with him ultimately.
不是吗？而不是那种所向披靡、戴着尖顶头盔的……我同意这一点，是的。我的意思是，这并不是要免除他的责任以及他实际上所做的事情。我的意思是，最终责任在他这里。
He's not only the head of state, but also the commander-in-chief of the armed forces. So he could have put his foot down, I suppose. But then when you look at just intellectually, I think he neither had the capability nor the patience to actually sit there and work it all out. So I think in many ways, I wouldn't say he was played by the militaries,
他不仅是国家元首，也是武装部队的总司令。所以我想他本可以态度强硬一些的。但当你从智力上看，我认为他既没有能力也没有耐心真正坐在那里把这一切理清。所以我觉得在很多方面，我不会说他是被军方玩弄了，
but he was certainly not, I think, capable of seeing the bigger picture of this and just allowed himself to be, I don't know, kind of intrigued, I guess, by the prospect of war and by being able to try all of his new shiny toys that he'd been developing in the last 10, 20 years. I think that's a huge aspect, his childlike fascination for all things technological and military and things.
但他肯定没有，我认为，看清这件事全貌的能力，只是让自己，我不知道，有点被战争的前景所吸引，能够尝试他在过去10年、20年里一直在开发的所有闪亮的新玩具。我认为这是一个巨大的方面，他对于所有技术和军事以及诸如此类的事情有着孩子般的热情。
Not only military, but he loved his technology as well. And to sit there with all of those new, know dreadnought class ships and whatever and he sits there and and wonders you know what will they actually do what will it be like and you know that i wouldn't underestimate as a psychological factor that he just wanted to see it live and in an action and and he wore the wrong yachting shoes to cows, didn't he? Which I'm sure had a devastating psychological effect. This is something deeply rooted in your own subconscious, clearly. This is the second time in these podcasts that you've mentioned the issue of yachting shoes. I'll tell you what it is.
不仅是军事，他也非常喜欢他的科技。坐在那里看着所有那些崭新的，你知道的无畏舰级别的船只和诸如此类东西，他坐在那里纳闷，你知道的，它们到底会做什么，会是什么样子，你知道的，我不会低估这是一个心理因素，他只是想亲眼看到它投入实况和行动中，而且他穿错了去考斯的游艇鞋，不是吗？我确信这对心理造成了毁灭性的影响。这是深深植根于你自己的潜意识里的东西，很明显。这是你在这些播客中第二次提到游艇鞋的问题。我来告诉你这是怎么回事。
I had a friend who's at school, whose father was a captain to ship in the Falklands. And one of the perks is that you could get a yacht and sail around the Isle of Wight and it was one of the worst four days of my life and I remember we pulled into the harbour at cows and I looked at people kind of walking up and down the uh the quay and I've never felt as jealous of anyone and I've always felt some fellow feeling with the Kaiser who turned up and had a miserable time at Cows. But enough of me and the Kaiser. One person who I think we perhaps haven't talked about enough is Bismarck. And I wonder how influential is Bismarck on this?
我上学时有个朋友，他父亲是福克兰群岛上一艘船的舰长。福利之一就是你可以弄一艘游艇在怀特岛周围航行，那是我生命中最糟糕的四天之一，我记得我们将船驶入考斯的港口，我看着人们在码头上走来走去，我从来没有对任何人感到如此嫉妒，我总是对去考斯却度过了一段悲惨时光的德皇有一种同病相怜的感觉。但我和德皇的事就说到这儿吧。还有一个我们可能还没怎么讨论过的人，那就是俾斯麦。我想知道俾斯麦对这件事有多大影响力？
We have a question from Pat Cooper who says, if Bismarck had come 30 years earlier, would we have been talking about a global Prussian German empire rather than a British empire? I mean, I guess that's kind of bundling into the idea of German ambitions overseas that perhaps we could also look at. But more generally, you know, is Bismarck an illustration of the great man theory? Or is he born on a kind of hegelian tide of you know the spirit of these he's merely the spokesman for the spirit of the agent it will if you were talking about hegelian tides at cows tom i'm not surprised that you didn't fit in with the yachting yes i was debagged um i think if ever there was an example that that theory, the great man theory still has any validity, I think Bismarck must surely be it.
我们有一个来自帕特·库珀的问题，他说，如果俾斯麦早出现30年，我们谈论的是不是就会是一个全球性的普鲁士-德国帝国，而不是大英帝国？我的意思是，我想这有点类似于德国海外野心的观点，也许我们也可以看看。但更广泛地说，你知道吗，俾斯麦是伟大人物理论的一个例证？还是说他诞生在某种黑格尔式的潮流中，你知道的，时代的精神，他仅仅是时代精神的发言人？汤姆，如果你要在考斯谈论黑格尔式的潮流，难怪你穿错游艇鞋了。是的，我被扒得只剩内衣了。我认为，如果说还有哪个例子能证明那个理论，即伟大人物理论仍然具有某种有效性，那俾斯麦一定首当其冲。
I mean, it's hard to see how things would have panned out the same way without him. It's just a sheer audacity to do what he did, I think, when everybody else looked at it and went, no, that's not possible. You can't do it. And, you know, starting with that speech, with that blood and iron speech, when you look at Willem had struggled with... So tell us about that, for those who may not be familiar with it, among which is me.
我的意思是，很难想象如果没有他，事情会以同样的方式发展。这纯粹是那种敢作敢为的勇气，去做他所做的事情，我想，当其他所有人都看着并说，不，这不可能。你做不到。而且，你知道的，从那次演讲开始，从那次血铁演讲开始，当你看到威廉一直在挣扎……那么给我们讲讲那个，对于可能不熟悉它的人来说，其中包括我。
In 18... So Bismarck was actually in France. He was the ambassador to France in 1861. And there's a reason for that, because Willem I, who would later become the German Kaiser, had only just become the king of Prussia and was a bit frightened of this kind of quite outrageous you know Prussian aristocrat who's very outspoken and very direct and didn't seem to have any respect for anyone really and so he sent him off first to St.
18……所以俾斯麦实际上在法国。他于1861年担任驻法国大使。这背后是有原因的，因为后来成为德国皇帝的威廉一世刚刚成为普鲁士国王，对这个相当离谱的、你知道的直言不讳、非常直接、似乎对谁都没有真正尊重的普鲁士贵族有点害怕，所以他先把他派到圣彼得堡，
Petersburg and then to France as the ambassador you you know, so he'd be kind of safely tucked away. But he was good at diplomacy. So it kind of worked both ways. But he struggled with Parliament internally, with the Prussian Parliament, because he needed to reform the army, as I was saying, to get rid of those volunteer units who seemed quite dangerous. And Parliament was obviously at that point, you know, full of liberals. So they were sat there going, absolutely not, because these people are on our side and they're kind of our lever to get the king to do what we want the king to do. So that led to such desperation that Wilhelm was actually on the brink of abdicating and thought at that point, you know, I can't do this. I need to hand over to Frederick, what will later become Frederick III, much in this in his mindset married to queen victoria's oldest daughter vicky so that would have worked because parliament would
然后作为大使派到法国，你知道的，这样他就可以被安稳地打发走。但他擅长外交。所以某种程度上双管齐下。但他在内部与议会、与普鲁士议会进行了艰难的斗争，因为他需要改革军队，正如我所说，为了摆脱那些看起来相当危险的志愿部队。而当时议会显然，你知道的，充满了自由主义者。所以他们坐在那里说，绝对不行，因为这些人站在我们这一边，他们某种程度上是我们用来让国王做我们想让国王做的事的筹码。这导致了极度的绝望，以至于威廉实际上处于退位的边缘，当时想，你知道的，我做不下去了。我需要把权力移交给腓特烈，也就是后来的腓特烈三世，他的心态非常倾向于迎娶维多利亚女王的长女维琪，所以这本来是行得通的，因为议会将
have you know got on with them and they would have kind of pulled in the same direction and it's at that point when you look at the influence that bismarck has he pulls him back from from france he comes back and just tells parliament well no we are reforming the military whether you want to or not and illegally goes ahead against the constitution goes ahead and just does it and parliament just sit there and go you can't do that it's against the law and he goes well try and stop me what are you going to do and just does it you know it is in that context that he tells them with that blood and iron speech i'm sorry but it's not your speeches not your niceties not your legalities that people will respect about prussia
会，你知道的，和他们相处得很好，他们会朝着同一个方向努力，正是在那个时候，当你看到俾斯麦的影响力时，他把他从法国拉了回来，他回来了，直接告诉议会，不，不管你们愿意与否，我们都要进行军事改革，并且违宪地非法继续推进，直接去做，而议会就坐在那里说，你不能那样做，那是违法的，而他说，有本事阻止我，你们打算怎么办，然后就直接做了，你知道的，正是在这种背景下，他用那次血铁演讲告诉他们，对不起，人们对普鲁士尊重的不是你们的演讲，不是你们的客套，不是你们的合法性，
it's force it's blood and. We need to have this army. And so he just does it. He actually reigns without parliamentary approval for that budget until I think it's 1874, I think, when he finally actually goes back to parliament after Germany had been created and says, oh, can you just approve my budget in hindsight, please, for all of those years that I reigned without it? And at that point, they haven't got a choice. They just go with it. And it's kind of made legal in hindsight afterwards. And so there, for instance, you know, the king is in despair. The king sits there and thinks he has to listen to parliament. And it's Bismarck that comes back
而是力量，是血与。我们需要这支军队。所以他就这么做了。实际上他在没有得到议会批准的情况下统治，没有批准那个预算，直到我想是1874年，当德国建立后，他终于回到议会说，哦，你能事后批准我的预算吗，为了我没有预算而统治的那些年？而在那个点上，他们别无选择。他们只能顺从。随后它在事后被某种程度上合法化了。所以，举个例子，国王陷入了绝望。国王坐在那里，认为他必须听取议会的意见。而俾斯麦回来了，
and goes, well, what are they going to do? Let's just not bother. And builds that army and fights those unification wars. and it's the same with with the Franco-Prussian war it's hard to see how anybody else would have had the audacity to provoke the French to the degree that he did so that they would actually attack knowing full well they can't win the war I mean how do you provoke a country in attacking another country when that country is perfectly aware of the fact that they have two-thirds as they phrased it of everything that that Germany had one-third sorry they had this kind of weird fact that they have two thirds, as they phrased it, of everything that Germany had. One third, sorry, they had this kind of weird idea that everything that the French have,
说，嗯，他们能怎么样？我们别理他们了。并建立那支军队，打那些统一战争。普法战争也是如此，很难想象还有谁会有这样的勇气将法国人激怒到他那种程度，以至于他们真的会发动进攻，明知自己无法赢得战争。我的意思是，当一个国家完全意识到他们拥有德国所拥有的“三分之二”（按他们的说法）的一切时，你如何挑衅一个国家去攻击另一个国家？对不起，是一分之三，他们有这种奇怪的说法，即法国拥有的每一样东西，
the Germans have two things of, be that people, money, anything. So, you know, those two things alone, I think, just show his individual actions and the consequences that they had, for better or worse, however you want to see that. But he's certainly an influential figure. And without him, I think the wars wouldn't have happened then and how they happened and germany wouldn't have been unified in 1871 with all the consequences that that had katya we're running a bit out of time i reckon um but i really wanted to ask um because it's a huge question about germany's relationship now with its past um When most ordinary Germans, I'm not talking about historians or intellectuals, but most ordinary Germans look at their own past or think about Germany, do they still do so with any sense of sort of trauma or guilt?
德国都有两份，无论是人、钱还是任何东西。所以，你知道的，仅凭这两点，我认为，就足以展现他的个人行动以及这些行动所带来的后果，无论是好是坏，无论你想怎么看。但他绝对是一个有影响力的人物。如果没有他，我认为战争就不会在那个时候发生，也不会以那种方式发生，德国也不会在1871年实现统一，并带来这一切后果。卡蒂亚，我们的时间快不够了，我想，但我真的很想问，因为这是一个关于德国现在与其过去的关系的巨大问题，
Or do they now regard it as other European countries regard their own past as something that is, you know, is gone, belongs to somebody else, and they don't need to sort of beat themselves up about it anymore. What specifically about Prussia or just all of it? Well, I mean, Germany's history, you know, defeated in two world wars incredibly traumatically, you know, revolution in 1919, the Weimar Republic, which we haven't really talked about at all, which is a fantastic, interesting subject, but obviously so difficult and conflicted and then of course the experience of the Third Reich I mean that's so utterly different from how Britain thinks about the
当大多数普通的德国人，我不是指历史学家或知识分子，而是大多数普通的德国人回顾他们自己的过去或思考德国时，他们是否仍然带着某种创伤感或内疚感来看待它？还是说他们现在把它看作其他欧洲国家看待自己过去那样，是一件，你知道的，已经过去的事，属于别人，他们不再需要为此而自责了？具体是关于普鲁士还是全部？嗯，我是说，德国的历史，你知道的，在两次世界大战中遭受了极其痛苦的惨败，你知道的，1919年的革命，魏玛共和国（我们根本没有真正讨论过，这是一个非常棒、有趣的话题，但显然非常困难和充满冲突），然后当然还有纳粹帝国的经历，我的意思是，这与英国看待
20th century I mean that's the story of uh very contrasting relationships with Europe to some extent um and I'm wondering do Germans now contemplate that story with equanimity rather than with sort of breast beating and shame and all the rest of it? Well I think I mean in a recent article I called the Second World War this like black hole in German history that sucks everything into it that came before and after and I think that's still very much the case and everything seemingly before 1933 leads up to that and everything after 1945 goes back to it and i think that's still very much the case when i was at school i had to learn about the nazis like three times so we started at
20世纪的方式完全不同，我的意思是，这在某种程度上是一个与欧洲截然不同的关系的故事，我在想，德国人现在是以平静而不是捶胸顿足和羞耻之类的情绪来沉思这段历史吗？嗯，我认为，我的意思是，在最近的一篇文章中，我把第二次世界大战称为德国历史上的这个“黑洞”，它把之前和之后的一切都吸了进去，我认为现在仍然是这样，1933年之前的一切似乎都通向那里，1945年之后的一切又都回到了那里，而且我认为现在仍然是这样。我上学的时候，不得不学了大约三次纳粹的历史，所以我们从
some point in year eight and then revisited it at gcc level and then again at a level and at some point you're like well i know everything about that now can we do something else please um so there there is that sense that i think that it needs to be explained needs to be explored needs to be um reminded of what people need to be reminded of it um and i think you know when you look at the fact that this year is the 150th anniversary of of 1871 of the effectively the beginning of the german state there's no i wouldn't you know i wouldn't have expected like celebrations or anything but there isn't even sort of any, you know, like you'd normally expect, say with the Russian revolution, there was loads of museums and speeches and books and publications and whatnot.
八年级的某个时候开始，然后在GCSE阶段重新温习，接着在A-level阶段又学了一遍，在某个时候你会想，好吧，关于那个我已经全知道了，我们能学点别的吗？所以确实有那种感觉，我认为它需要被解释，需要被探索，需要被，人们需要被提醒它，需要被提醒它，而且我认为，你知道的，当你看到今年是1871年、实际上是德国建国150周年时，根本没有，你知道的，我不会期望有什么庆祝活动之类的，但甚至没有任何，你知道的，通常你会期望的，比如说俄罗斯革命，会有大量的博物馆、演讲、书籍和出版物之类。
And there's very, very little in Germany. There's a little bit on the Franco-Prussian war specifically, but not on the fact that Germany was founded then, because people don't really know what to do with that legacy. The moment you commemorate it, you've got to interpret it in some way. And then what you do, as you say, always lead back to both of those wars and you end up once again discussing it in that light. And Bismarck is perhaps a good example of that. He's very, very difficult for a lot of Germans to deal with because, yes, on the one hand side, you know, you created the welfare state and you've got all of those kind of achievements.
而在德国，却非常非常少。关于普法战争本身有一点点，但不是关于德国在那时成立这一事实，因为人们真的不知道如何处理这份遗产。你一纪念它，就必须以某种方式解读它。然后正如你所说，你所做的一切总是引导回这两场战争，你最终再次在那种光照下讨论它。而俾斯麦也许就是一个很好的例子。对许多德国人来说，他非常非常难以应对，因为，是的，一方面，你知道的，你创建了福利国家，你取得了所有这些成就。
But then people sit there and go, oh, but he only did it because of, you know, the threat of socialism and all the rest of it. So there's always, you know, even with Bismarck, there's a huge amount of ambiguity there and people don't really know what to do with him. So he's just got ignored more and more, I find, certainly in the 90s and early 2000s. It seems to be coming back a little bit now, again, the attention on Bismarck. But Wilhelm as well, you know, you've got two big Wilhelm biographers. One is Roel, who's British.
但人们坐在那里却说，哦，但他这样做只是因为，你知道的，社会主义的威胁和其余的一切。所以总是，你知道的，即使对于俾斯麦，也有大量的模棱两可，人们真的不知道该拿他怎么办。所以他被越来越多地忽视了，我发现，肯定是在90年代和2000年代初。现在似乎又有点回来了，对俾斯麦的关注又回来了。但威廉也是，你知道的，你有两位伟大的威廉传记作家。一位是勒尔，他是英国人。
The other one is Christopher Clarke, who's Australian. Roel hates Wilhelm, doesn't he? I mean, he absolutely hates him. I find that a bit interesting with Clarke who's Australian. And Roel hates Wilhelm, doesn't he? I mean, he absolutely hates him. I find that a bit interesting with Clarke as well when both in this Prussia book and in the Wilhelm biography he starts off not wanting to like both of them, I feel. And then kind of as he did his research and as he carried on writing about them
另一个是克里斯托弗·克拉克，他是澳大利亚人。勒尔讨厌威廉，对吧？我的意思是，他非常讨厌他。我发现克拉克也是这样，这挺有趣的，克拉克是澳大利亚人，而勒尔讨厌威廉，对吧？我的意思是，他非常讨厌他。我发现克拉克身上也有这一点挺有意思的，无论是在这本普鲁士书中还是在威廉的传记中，他一开始都不想喜欢他们两个，我感觉是这样。然后随着他做研究，随着他继续撰写关于他们的文章，
becomes a little bit more sympathetic towards them. But I find it interesting that no German historian wants to touch Wilhelm with a barge pole. That's, you know, yes, there is a lot of Prussian history, but that always focuses on Frederick the Great and those supposedly good Prussian days and years. And then
变得对他们多了一点同情。但我发现有趣的是，没有一个德国历史学家想用十英尺长的杆子去碰威廉。那是，你知道的，是的，有很多普鲁士历史，但那总是集中在腓特烈大帝和那些所谓的普鲁士好日子和好年头。然后
it's again, you know, let's go back to Prussian militarism and see how it led to the First World War and then the Second World War. Well, Katja, I can't thank you enough. I mean, you said the Second World War is a kind of black hole in German history, but I think you've really done brilliantly in keeping us from falling too deeply into that black hole. It's been so interesting to try and look at Prussia kind of through the eyes of 19th century, I guess, rather than the mid-20th century.
又是，你知道的，让我们回到普鲁士军国主义，看看它是如何导致第一次世界大战然后是第二次世界大战的。好吧，卡蒂亚，我真是感激不尽。我的意思是，你说第二次世界大战是德国历史上的某种黑洞，但我认为你真的做得太出色了，阻止了我们陷得太深而掉进那个黑洞。试图通过19世纪、我猜是19世纪的眼光而不是20世纪中期的眼光来看待普鲁士，这真的太有趣了。
So I can't thank you enough. I can't thank everyone. Thanks to everyone else for listening today uh at the moment we're releasing podcasts twice a week on mondays and thursdays and i hope with subjects broad enough to appeal to most tastes so auf wiedersehen thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
所以我真是感激不尽。我无法感谢所有人。谢谢今天收听的其他人，目前我们每周一和周四发布两次播客，我希望这些主题足够广泛，能够吸引大多数人的口味，那么再见，感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。